This is I'd like to know. Bible
questions, Biblebased answers. Thank you
for joining us today. My name is Sierra
Murray. To my left, Pastor David
Salazar. To my right, Pastor Steven Boy.
Gentlemen, again, always a pleasure to
study the word of God with you.
>> Amen.
Thank you for joining us and thank you
for sending in your questions. If you
would like to get a question sent in or
uh a question answered, we would invite
you to send your questions to tv at some
su m as in marytv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org
and we will get to your questions. When
you send in your questions, would you
please tell us where you are writing
from? It gives us a little bit of an
idea of the footprint of the ministry
and how we are touching lives around the
world. So we thank you in advance for
that. Pastor Bo, would you ask God's
blessing upon our sitting today and then
we'll launch out.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, uh we come
before you this morning with humility of
heart because uh we are going to
undertake a very important activity and
that is to answer the questions of those
who have sent them in. give us divine
enlightenment in our minds. Give us
words to speak that are in harmony with
your word.
>> And I ask Lord that uh you will continue
to bless uh Secrets Unsealed. And I'd
like to know and all of the programs
that we do here whose only purpose is to
exalt your name and to inform your
people. We thank you father for hearing
our prayer. In Jesus name we pray. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Um, our first question
comes from, he states Brown, but in the
email I see Enoch has maybe his first
name. So, um, Enoch Brown, if that is
indeed your name, thank you for your
question. Um, and he says, "I like your
programs." Uh, we do too. Praise the
Lord. [laughter]
He says, "I want you to help me with
Adventist youth and Pathfinder
Club practices.
I know many people who have taken
offense and refused to join the SDA
church because of the salutes,
military-like drills, uniforms, hats,
marching, etc. of these clubs. Where in
the Bible does it say the apostolic
church has such practices or had rather
such practices?
The Bible says nowhere that the
apostolic church had such practices.
That doesn't mean that those practices
cannot exist in the church.
>> Uh the church as it grows, it looks for
ways to uh to satisfy the needs of
people. The church grows. For example,
there is nothing in the New Testament
about cooking demonstrations in the
church.
the Apostolic Church, you don't find any
place where it says the demonstrating
vegetarian foods.
So that's off limits. We don't do
cooking demos. We don't do health
lectures because none of those things
are in the New Testament. Of course not.
You know, as long as what is done in the
church does not contradict
what the New Testament church did, um we
can actually do those things. Now,
having been a Pathfinder director of a
conference or two conferences for a
period of 10 years,
I'm very well acquainted with uh
Pathfinders and with Adventurers. I'm
also very acquainted with youth
ministries because I was the youth
director in New Jersey for six years.
So, so I'm very well acquainted. Uh it
reminds me of uh an something that was
organized when the Vietnam War was going
on. The MCC's.
>> I know that we're we're contemporaries.
>> So MCC's medical cadet corp
was established in the church.
>> No place does it say the apostolic
church had medical cadet corp.
>> Yes.
>> Why was it established? to prepare our
young people who had to go into the
service as medics to know what to
expect.
>> Yes.
>> So it was very good. It was very good in
the church. Uh Pathfinders has been
criticized because uh you know there's
marches and there's uh all different
kinds of activities, camperees and so
on. Um the Pathfinder Church actually
the Pathfinders
are an auxiliary organization of the
church. In other words, they help the
church fulfill its mission. I could tell
you many stories of people that have
come into the church because their kids
belong to Pathfinders.
>> Amen.
>> In other words, it's an outreach thing.
>> Furthermore, Pathfinders lo learn a lot
of practical things for life. They learn
discipline. They learn order. They they
learn cleanliness.
Uh they learn uh to to get along with
one another. Uh in other words, it's a
very blessed um program that has been
established in the church. So um you
know just because the apostolic church
doesn't mention pathfinders and doesn't
mention a medical cadet corp and so on
um it doesn't mean that the church
cannot carry on these activities as long
as the church doesn't establish it only
as entertainment but establish it
establishes it in some way to fulfill
the mission of the church to better
people's lives and to preach the gospel.
>> Amen. I think that, you know, it's it's
important to know that there are these
programs and these clubs that, like you
said, Pastor Bo, that were implemented
in the church to help young people
prepare, be equipped, be able to uh
participate to to know more about the
Bible. Well, I mean, if if you look at
the the Pathfinder,
you know, booklet and the things they
have to do, uh, you can really be
benefit from that. Um, I've seen clubs
that have really, uh, I think taking the
right spirit and you can also do wrong
by mis applying or making it only about
having fun, right? And and perhaps
that's what has happened in some places.
I mean we have to be aware of that
situation where uh certain clubs have
been about just having fun and not
really understanding or giving the tools
to young people to grow spiritually to
grow in understanding the Bible to be
quick in their you know uh physical
activities and that kind of thing to be
alert to to develop you know mind heart
and body uh for the Lord. So I do think
that there is great benefits if the the
leadership of the church the local
church the the pathfinder pastor pastor
or or or guide uh is really doing the
work and like I said I've seen very good
things out of that and there is
situations where there's other uh
unfortunately
clubs who have not done right and I know
that in some countries even has become
sadly some about you know dancing
involved and these things that are
really dishonoring God. I mean, this is
not just about the club itself. It's
about churches that have, you know,
embraced worldly practices. And so, uh,
you know, you have to not put everything
together and they're one, you know,
umbrella. Um, if the church where you go
has a good biblically sound and and are
following the the the curriculum of the
Pathfinders, I think there's going to be
a great benefit for the youth as long as
they follow what the church is
implementing.
>> Sure. uh outside of that if you see the
club that is leading or leaning into
another direction then you may be you
know in love called back to make sure
that the club fulfills its role and it
purpose and it's not going to be against
the church but going to benefit the
church going to uh really be an asset
for the young people
>> and that would be true of any program
>> any program the church absolutely
>> you know uh programs have a tendency to
go off track
>> yes
>> but just because they go off track
doesn't mean that if they're done
correctly they cannot be a benefit to
the church.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh you know,
>> I go to New Jersey now and then as for
speaking commitments
>> and invariably I have somebody come up
and say, "Hey pastor, I remember that
camperee that we had in Pennsylvania,
the friendship camperee." And uh there
it's a program that really is
instrumental in keeping
people in the church.
>> There you go. There you uh retaining
people in the church because there's
kids that belong to Pathfinders when I
go to New Jersey and to Texico
conference that still remember the
Pathfinder activities and they're still
in the church.
>> Yeah.
>> And so uh we need to keep Pathfinders on
track. Yes.
>> You know, there've been even division
camperees that went off track of course
>> with dancing and shouting after the
Sabbath started and everything. you know
that just because things are done wrong
does not mean that the program itself
>> uh does does not benefit the church when
it is carried on correctly.
>> Amen. That's the most important thing.
>> I think one of the greatest
uh areas where we need a lot of nuance
and texture is youth activities in
general. Mhm.
>> The truth is um
older people don't think like younger
people.
>> They don't.
>> We have to
create mechanisms
that give young people a an avenue to
expend a lot of that energy
>> that are godly.
>> Right.
>> I remember years ago we went on a a
mission trip and the young people were
up all night and and just wouldn't go to
bed. And uh so us old heads got together
the conference
academy president myself the education
[clears throat] student said we're going
to work these kids so hard that they'll
just fall out at night and go to sleep.
Well we worked them so hard we fell out
at night and they kept on working.
That's that's the thing about young
people. You've got this this boundless
energy. You know you so you you got to
you've got to give them some mechanisms
to to expend that energy constructively
and redemptively.
>> Right. Um, so you can't just lock them
down.
>> And as you as you both have said,
anytime you have anything that man is
involved in, there is the opportunity
for abuse.
>> But because there's the opportunity for
abuse does not mean you throw the baby
out with the bathwater.
>> Yeah.
>> Pathfinders is a good thing. I've seen
Pathfinder clubs in Africa, hundreds of
members strong,
>> marching and and doing things. And in
Panama, they have the Pathfinders do
this thing called mission kaleb. They go
into community, they paint houses, they
cut grass, they clean garbage. Uh these
are pathfinders in their uniforms uh
doing great great things for for the
Lord. Uh so we we've got to balance
that. If it's lifting up Jesus, if it's
done in a wholesome way that is
redemptive, I think we can support it
and give our young people something to
do. I can go in a room, grab a book, and
sit down for most of the afternoon. Uh
my grandson can't do that. He's not
going to do that. [laughter] You know,
he's not going to do that. Got to find
something for him to do. So, let's give
them something to do that lifts them and
draws them closer to Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> Thank you for that that question. Uh,
Brown and thank you gentlemen for your
answers. All righty. Mark Connor from
Iona, Michigan. Praise the Lord. I Ionia
Ionia miss Michigan. My question
concerns the application of the story
found in First Kings 20 uh 35-43. We're
going to have to turn and read that so
we get some context. Who's going to read
that for me?
>> I can have it, Pastor.
>> All right. As you're turning, let me
finish the question. Someone I know has
been having an email exchange with an
elder of a church concerning a
controversial topic. The elder has
decided to stop responding to emails.
Based on the story of First Kings 20, is
it okay for this person to pretend to be
someone else and use a and use a false
name so that the elder will respond to
his emails thinking it is someone who
hasn't previously who he hasn't
previously dialogued with. Blessings to
you and your ministry. Um, interesting.
Thank you, Mark, for for your questions.
All right, let's go to the story uh
where this individual seems to find the
basis to um use another name. This is
found in first kings chap 20 35
to 43 and I'll read now a certain man of
the sons of the prophets said to the
neighbor by the word of the lord strike
me please and the men refused to strike
him. Then he said to him, "Because you
have not obeyed the voice of the Lord,
surely as soon as you depart from me, a
lion shall kill you." And as soon as he
left, as he had left him, a lion found
him and killed him. And he found another
man and said, "Strike me, please." So
the man struck him, inflicting a wound.
Then the prophet departed and waited for
the king by the road and disgued himself
with a bandage over his eyes. Now, as
the king passed by, he cried out to the
king and said, "Your servant went out
into the midst of the battle. And there
a man came over and brought a man to me
and said, "Guard this man. If by any
means he's missing, your life shall be
for his life, or else you shall pay a
talent of silver." While your servant
was busy here, and there he was gone.
Then the king of Israel said to him, "So
shall your judgment be, you yourself
have decided."
and he hastened to take the bandage away
from his eye and the king of Israel
recognized him as one of the prophets.
Then he said to him, "Thus says the
Lord, because you have left, you have
let slipped out of your hand a man whom
I appointed to utter destruction,
therefore your life shall go for his
life and your people for his people." So
the king of Israel went to his house
sulent and displeased and came to
Samaria.
So that's an interesting story of Ahab
condemned for letting go of a man the
Lord had told him to destroy and the the
prophet this guy himself disguise
himself for for to be able to share this
message to him. So I guess this is where
they find it as a basis for them to
disguise disguise themselves and write
with another name. Um so your thoughts
pastor now that I write the Bible
>> there is a statement by Ellen G White
that I find very useful [clears throat]
in in certain situations. She says no
deviation from strict integrity
>> meet God's approval.
>> Sometimes you take shortcuts
in the feeling that it will get you out
of the exigency of the of the moment.
But long-term
truth will always be the best. You know,
we we have and and see the Bible shows
the good, the bad, and the ugly. Just
because it's in the Bible does not mean
the Bible is endorsing it,
>> right?
>> Uh the Gibeonites played a little trick
>> and and and got their lives spared but
became slaves for for forever. So, you
you can do little funny things like
that, but you're not honoring God and
you're not promoting God's kingdom when
you move away from the from strict
integrity.
Yeah. You know, [laughter]
I agree with you 100% that just because
the Bible has a story, it's not
necessarily condoning the story.
>> Precisely. Yeah.
>> Um, you know, the Bible, we believe the
Bible is truth.
>> Um, always tell the truth.
Never attempt to deceive.
>> Uh, you know, the spirit is the spirit
of truth.
>> Yes. Jesus is the truth.
Nathaniel, there was no lie in his
mouth.
>> Told the truth.
>> Time and again in the New Testament, you
find the importance of the truth.
>> They they were condemned because they
did not receive the love of the truth.
Second Thessalonians,
>> it's always right to tell the truth.
>> And it's always wrong to deceive.
>> You say, "But what?" Just to give you an
example, during the second world war,
you've heard of Corey
>> Tenboom,
>> you know, the Gestapo came to her house
and uh they were looking for a certain
individual and she was hiding that
individual. And so she hid the
individual uh under a table that had a
long tablecloth.
And the Gestapo asked her, they said,
"Do you have such and such a person
here?" She says, "Yeah, I do. He's right
under the table." They say, "We're not
fooling around. Be serious." And they
left. You know, if he was under the
table, would she really say that this
person was under the table?
>> The thing is, we want to take things
into our own hands. That's the key.
>> We say God is not powerful enough to
deliver this person. So, we have to lie
to kind of save him.
>> No. No.
>> You tell the truth and you leave the
consequences with God. Ellen White makes
has a statement where she says we are
always to tell the truth and you leave
the consequences with God.
>> Um
truth is always the best policy.
>> Uh it's never right to use deception.
>> Amen. And like you said, both of you
said, you know, the Bible gives you this
story. And in this story specifically
that we read, there's a man of a prophet
of God who is instructed to get hit and
put this
bandage over his head to appear as
someone that is wounded with a message
for the king. Um I doubt that any of us
have been given such a specific
instructions
>> to make a point. Um we have to
understand that this particular story
was given for a prophet who needed to
give a message in a way that Ahab was
going to
receive the message.
How the Lord used that um is not
condoning the accept the idea of
disguising ourselves or or or lying or
trying to deceive somebody. Again, this
is a practical lesson for someone in the
particular case of Ahab to receive a man
who you know king who was continually
trying to not do the Lord's will. And so
um for that particular reason, God had
given instructions that he had been hit
that that he was to appear bloody and
and all that kind of thing to present a
message that was going to remember why
and how they have failed. But to use
that to say, you know, now let me try to
disguise myself, try to act as someone
who is not. I have, let me be wrong,
I've been tempted myself. Some of, for
example, I've seen some uh individuals
who uh are very aggressive at, you know,
posting and and and speaking ill about
something or someone. And sometimes you
are tempted like, man, I wish I could
give them a message, but I don't want to
know it's me. And you could be tempted
to, you know, put somebody, you know,
that that's not that's not true. That's
not how you're supposed to be. You're
supposed to be like you said, but you
know, be faithful. And I when I prayed
about it, Lord, you know, clearly tells
me, don't even think about it. So no
longer I have that temptation, you know,
but at one point in my life, it was like
something that I could I could almost
feel like it was important. But again,
are you trying to make your argument,
your point valid? Uh, you know, pray
what about pray to the Lord. Say, look,
impress that individual to change his
mind. If he's doing wrong, let him, you
know,
let him come to the conclusion or let me
be more loving towards him. Maybe my
approach was wrong. let me approach him
by you know serving him and honoring him
and loving him and giving him a time to
learn to become or to know the truth. So
I think that there's many ways you can
go about but this particular way trying
to use deception is not the way that God
approves.
>> Yeah. You know there's a prime example
and there of course there are many
examples of the way in which people
misuse scripture.
>> Yeah. For example, in 1 Corinthians
chapter 15, the Apostle Paul tells the
Corinthians, you know, if the dead don't
resurrect, why do you baptize for the
dead?
>> And so, there's a church that has
established an entire doctrine
>> based on that
>> with that one verse.
>> Yes.
>> And of course, with the embellishment in
Pearl of Great Price and, you know,
other publications,
is the Apostle Paul saying you're
supposed to baptize for the dead? He's
not saying you're supposed to baptize
for the dead. He's saying, "Why are you
baptizing for the dead if you don't
believe in the resurrection?" He's just
making a statement of what they're
doing.
>> Precisely.
>> He's not He's not making a statement
that you're supposed to baptize for the
dead. But people will take
>> a text, they'll give it a twist
>> to say something that the text is not
really saying.
>> And and that happens more frequently
than not
>> even among Christians.
>> And usually is the motivation of your
heart. If you're honest, you know why
you wanna, you know, in this particular
case, why do he wants to continue
emailing and going back and forth? He
wants to still argue and have a dispute
with brother without because he's not
responding to his email. So now I'm
going to find a way to still, you know,
tell him and and and that's the thing.
It's like, what do you want to
accomplish? I don't know if the spirit
of God is leading you. If the spirit of
God is leading you, uh I don't think
this is the way to approach. You know,
you have to wait till God impresses the
heart. Uh maybe you need to come more in
a humble of a spirit, have more
humility, meekness and and and love your
brother who maybe is not particularly,
you know, doing the right thing, but but
showing him through the word of God,
through your experience that you love
him and and that you can have peace and
and and may put away these divisions and
whatnot in their own experience.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> I was going to say less you think, Mark,
that we are condemning you, we are we
are not. But sometimes it is best to
step back and and and bring your ego out
of out of the thing. Um
let the Lord lead. Uh I can recall many
Bible studies where I wanted to land
that haymaker and just bring them across
the line for the Lord and a person would
just resist it. You know, they just
there was no no bomb I could drop on
them to have them come crying to the
foot of the cross. So you you do what is
what you can do. You pray for an opening
from the Lord and then put it in God's
hands. I'm sorry, pastor.
>> You know, I'm reminded of a book that
was written by a man called Joseph
Fletcher.
>> The title of the book, Situation Ethics.
>> So, he says, "Certain situations require
you to lie.
>> Certain situations [clears throat] might
even lead you to commit adultery uh to
so that the situation uh you know is is
resolved in a loving way. In other
words, when when
love
so-called replaces what God's laws,
then you're following the wicked
inclinations of your heart.
>> Yes.
>> And the heart is wicked above all
things. Who can know it? The next verse
is I the Lord
>> can know it.
>> And so, you know, the best polic honesty
is the best policy.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, the saying goes,
>> let's just be honest. Let's tell the
truth and leave the consequences with
God. Amen.
>> And we'll always be on solid ground.
Amen. Yeah.
>> I I like that thought. Leave the
consequences with God. God is still on
the throne. He has not advocated his
responsibility. Uh usually you try to
fudge the truth or massage the truth to
get out of a hot,
>> you know, a tight situation. But uh it
does not help. It doesn't lead uh to
anything good and it does not glorify
the father.
>> Uh God is able. He is able and he can
keep and he can resurrect. So keep that
in mind in all of your doing. Again, our
time has fast slipped into eternity.
Allow me in closing to wish you both
grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see see you
again soon. Bye-bye and God bless.